Democrats have objected or or rejected
the the results of every Republican
president going back like several
decades or something and then they were
like mostly true mostly true and it's
like how is that not true they literally
do they get up and they say this is
illegitimate there was voters who are
disenfranchised or whatever and then
we're supposed to just act like
they're not lying when they call other
people election deniers or something
we do at one time and had one party at
the Capitol and everything that's what
they're waiting for but that's the thing
we're talking about eleven two is what
you're referring to we were talking
about it earlier you know that uh
they just the left acts like it doesn't
happen if if the hunter Biden laptop
stuff it comes out it's a mountain of
evidence we can all see it they just
plug their plug their ears close their
eyes and walk away and then say what are
you talking about I'm just talking about
yep and that's it so uh we're supposed
to engage with that I don't know this is
why I'm my attitude has kind of just
been like let's perhaps ignore them